this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you know
the cash app it's the simplest way to
instantly send money to friends it's
also the number one happened finance but
it didn't get there on payments alone
these days cash app is changing how
people interact with their money it's
adding features you can only get from a
bank and more than a few that you can't
like the cash card boosts and Bitcoin
download the cash up for free on the App
Store or Google Play market we're back
in business babies we are back in
business episode 85 we're live on the
[ __ ] app and we're also I'm a quick
I'm a sick [ __ ] I like the quick [ __ ]
I'm a sick [ __ ] like a quick [ __ ] have
you heard that song yet that Kanye West
one with blood pump where they look like
they're the [ __ ] Talking Heads is
that who used to wear those bok-bok see
ass shits yeah do it also it's not
really a sick [ __ ] if you look just like
a quick [ __ ] that's just you have [ __ ]
to do
I'm a sick [ __ ] I like the quick [ __ ] it
shouldn't be like that that's not it
that's not that sick I'm a sick it's he
might as well just being saying I'm a
sick [ __ ] I like to just [ __ ] I'm a sick
[ __ ] I like to [ __ ] I'm busy he should
just be it would make sense if he was
like I'm a sick [ __ ] I like to [ __ ] on
chest I'm a sick [ __ ] I like to [ __ ] on
glass table we have your face under it
have you ever seen that where somebody
takes a [ __ ] on a glass table and it
almost hit your face why do I know it
anyway dude we're here it's episode 80
[ __ ] something 85 and work and we're
having a good time and I had weird
dreams last night and I woke up in the
middle of night and I thought I can't
wait to tell you guys what they are on
the podcast then I went back to sleep
again woke up again they're gone got no
idea what they [ __ ] work because
that's what dreams happen that's what
happens with dreams that's what happens
with dreams dreams are like a [ __ ]
chick you almost hooked up with and then
get a boyfriend and you're like
[ __ ] almost almost dream almost but uh
what we got to remember is I'm a sick
[ __ ] the like quit [ __ ] yeah dude this
is episode 85 and if you notice you're
live on the app already but I gotta tell
you my babies if you're gonna watch a
[ __ ] video podcast if you're ever
gonna watch a video podcast the my
baby's episode 85 is the one to watch
because and I know you're listening
right now before you [ __ ] watch some
of you guys do both but we did some
renovations dude we did some renovations
to the studio we had 40 men come in here
and some women because we're not sexist
we had 40 men and some women because
we're not sexist come in here and
rebuild the studio dude you can see it
and it's [ __ ] awesome dude it's
absolutely awesome and you guys got a
[ __ ] you guys got to see
you guys got to see it so go to the
video podcast and see that [ __ ] if
you're not on live on my app then you
know you got to [ __ ] go click on
YouTube in a day or whatever and you
might notice it's subtly hinting at
something ok you might notice it's
subtly hinting at something you might
notice it's not only hinting at
something and we got a sign here that
was made by I think Katherine something
it says on the back I'll take it off in
at the end but this is a fan-made dude
this congratulations with crystal they
assigned us fan-made now we're just
using it temporarily so don't get too
excited if that is you Katherine but you
know you give mortalized for a little
bit and so that's what's up but yeah so
we got a new [ __ ] we got new digs
here do it and we're killing it and
we're having a [ __ ] good time and
it's amazing what new digs could [ __ ]
do for ya make you feel good dude you
know they say things don't matter like
you know like how about when you get you
when you clean your house and it's all
clean and then you feel [ __ ] good
right what's that what's that what's
that you don't need to keep get your
house clean you don't need to paint your
walls but when you do you feel you know
what you feel lifted that's what you
feel you feel lifted do it
you feel like someone's [ __ ] carrying
you places that's what you feel like
let's pop the very a there we go mmm
drinking it let's pop the [ __ ]
caveman Nitra cold brew coffee giving up
giving to my buddy tate let's pop that
sounds pretty [ __ ] good hey we'll hit
the [ __ ] that's better than opening up
a can of something you know remember
when remember [ __ ] like 20 years ago
when people said I'm gonna open up a can
of whoop-ass on you and they thought it
was [ __ ] cool that's crazy dude
things become dorky immediately right
like immediately
it's not fair how quickly things become
dorky like hair you know what I'm
talking about if you look at yourself
five years ago and you don't think
what's up with that hair then you
[ __ ] have no literally no like like
your barometer is just completely off
for everything dude you just can't
understand what the [ __ ] life's about
cuz your hair five years ago sucked dude
you had guess what dude you whoever you
are listening you had bad hair five
years ago even if you had a full head of
hair and you're bald now you look better
now than you did because you looked you
looked so 90s five years ago you looked
so 90s it doesn't matter if it was just
2013 quick math uh-huh quick math 2018 -
5 2013 quick math I used to flirt with
girls like this I used to be like this I
used to have this night it wasn't like a
thing I did but I would be like dude I'm
so good at math and they'll be like
whatever and I'm like no no no I'm like
actually really [ __ ] good at math
give me two any two numbers single
digits don't give me two digit numbers
give me give me one digit numbers two of
them I will add them before you're even
done telling me what the second number
is and she'd be like wait lat and then I
have to explain it again of course and
she'd be like okay eight and five and
then I would be like wait what what and
she
say a ten phone should get 2f and I
would just be like [ __ ] 13 because
and then she was like what and it'd be
like okay give me two more okay
two and three and I'd say what and she'd
say to a tentative five there was a
little fun jokey thing man because you'd
be like you know you pretend you didn't
hear the first time innocent that's the
stuff I think they probably do on the
magic cat in the Magic Castle by the way
I'm a magician is basically what I'm
trying to say so anyway what was I
talking about I don't have a [ __ ]
clue what was I talking about math math
one fire ghosts math I mean I know that
I meant before it dude
I don't remember bro I don't [ __ ]
remember what feeling lifted oh yeah
dude you feel lifted when you paint your
walls paint your walls dude paint your
[ __ ] walls paint your [ __ ] walls
get done with it go to lunch and then
come back enjoy how you feel for real
dude for [ __ ] real Hey okay you know
what I actually want to talk about I put
it on my Instagram story
I eat [ __ ] Larabar bytes dude hey you
know what you should do for Larabar
bytes for real this is let me tell you
something man
you're a company this is what you do
okay I don't know if I've ever had a
Larabar I probably have but the Larabar
bytes you might as well just put them
directly in your [ __ ]
and then shut them out because they
taste like the packaging hey Lara bar
bites
get it tough [ __ ] gather
oh it's vegan cool there's a lot of good
people are like it's vegan what did you
expect
I don't give a [ __ ] bro there's vegan
places that are amazing there are vegan
places that I would choose to go to and
I don't even give a [ __ ] about like
being vegan but the Laura bar bites hey
get it together
there's so they taste you know what they
taste like this wall right here that's
what the
it's like hey Larabar bites you tastes
like a wall care for walls come on in
and get some Larabar bites dude they're
awful my buddy got them and he's like
are these suck and I was like no they
don't bro you're just [ __ ] cuz the guy
probably eats like four four loko and
and fun DEP I'm like your taste buds are
probably just not you know not
sophisticated sophisticated and I put it
in my mouth and I thought oh dude you
know the last time you know how bad a
candy has to be if you literally do you
know how bad a candy has to be to stop
at one like you give candy a second
chance
every time you could eat literally they
could be diarrhea bites they could be
diarrhea bites made by [ __ ] you know
any made by uh what do you call it a
canon camera anybody the guy that got no
business making making candy and it be
diarrhea bites and you'd be like all
right let me give it a second and third
chance these Larabar bites you get one
you get you put one in your mouth and
then you're done dude and because you're
like oh I'll never put that in my mouth
again and I put on my story and
everybody was DMing me like oh yeah
these are [ __ ] terrible oh yeah
they're awful oh yeah I tried them once
they're awful hey Larabar get it
together and I'll tell you two you get
one reminds me of something when my
brother used to do we used to go to the
Dodger game and Jeff Kent would play was
Jeff Kent on the Mets and the Dodgers
Jeff Kent anyway he looked like a
[ __ ] he was this baseball player that
was this action that looks literally
couldn't look more if you think of
action movie star in the 80s couldn't
look more like Jeff Kent the ball player
on [ __ ] New York Mets Toronto Blue
Jays Cleveland Indians San Francisco
Giants Houston Astros Los Angeles
Dodgers he's been on all those teams
okay and we would see him and you know
like you know like the
if you've ever been to a baseball game
when the batting when the batter plays
they'll put up his like [ __ ] picture
on the on the on the big Jumbotron thing
and it'll be like and it'd be like
number 45 Jeff Kent and then it would
show his picture and then like by the
way that song make a better song hey
I've got a word for you guy who scores
the batters when they're brick when
they're brought up [ __ ] - - at bat
I've got a word for you
try literally just took the [ __ ] a
board and just went and then one guy and
then they woke one guy up
oh wait that's a song that is that
that's the beginning of at the carwash
song it is no way we got to [ __ ] try
this this is what Wan Fire says which is
why we [ __ ] have him one higher this
is that's the beginning of a [ __ ]
real actual song I thought they were
just well then why the [ __ ] didn't they
pay to me at the car wash she's saying
well we got to play this at the I know
that song obviously gosh what video dude
this is what they play every time a
Dodger gets up by every ever though
every other time they have a few at the
carwash here we go
car wash movie clip oh yeah know what
that was a [ __ ] movie there's got to
be it I mean dude at the car wash video
there's so many [ __ ] up videos that
come up it's like I drove my car to the
carwash I'm gonna [ __ ] about that Rose
Royce a rose Royce dude
for [ __ ] sake this goddamn ad video
will play after ad it's the worst yeah
so anyway they will play this song and
Jeff Kent whoever would be batting would
be [ __ ] them up in it
wow dude this is a real song and have
way too many and like get a strike in a
foul ball and then a [ __ ] a few balls
dude it's kind of disrespectful that
they [ __ ] didn't name ball they just
called it a ball like a strike is a
strike and then if you if it's outside
of it it's called a ball right that's
like come up dude what you're just
calling it the thing that you throw bro
baseball hey baseball try harder dude
you know how much downtime there is for
a baseball player they could literally
just be like checking their email and
drinking a [ __ ] chocolate shake
literally in the field or in the dugout
do they have a place to hang out during
the game how [ __ ] hey baseball
players try at least do jumping jacks
when you're not at bat like dude they're
just [ __ ] they got their knee up just
eating they eat they eat during the game
they have [ __ ] chew theirs and then
in bubble gum
they eat sunflower seeds dude if you're
playing a sport where you can eat hey
give up play basketball I mean dude hey
oh yeah oh cool oh it's our turn at bat
oh cool oh nice how am I gonna beat up
this inning no probably not there's nine
of us okay alright well then I guess you
guys just go up and I'll take a break
by the way I
my [ __ ] right field and never do
anything
yeah balls get hit out to me sometimes
oh oh and baseball is the only sport
where you can have a [ __ ] fat
out-of-shape guy football they're fat
but they're in shape bro
but baseball you take too many breaks
dude oh hey how about this I'm the
designated hitter I do as much activity
physically as your mom ah oh hey yeah
I'll get up oh dude yeah I'm off I got a
fat gut and I eat during this sporting
event that I'm a part of I eat I eat and
chill oh you want me to bat cool hope I
hit a home run otherwise I've got a run
unbelievable dude that's actually
unbelievable and then baseball is so
lazy that they call the thing that's not
a strike a ball which is just the thing
that you throw now up to the plate
hensley mule ends we didn't come up with
a song we just got the most basic song
and then we'll end it before the good
part that's it that's what you hear at
least play this [ __ ] part
see it's too far it's too funky that's
why it's too funky player it's too much
you know what you know what they think
it is they think because it's America's
pastime they think it's disrespectful
that's what they do but in actuality
it's disrespectful to just play the
[ __ ] clap part of the thing dude I
mean you know what you know what they
should do you know what they should do
all the guys who don't hit that inning
that are just taking a break and the
designated hitter and maybe the guy who
plays left field why don't you guys get
together when the other guys are [ __ ]
having to hit and you guys come up with
a jingle come up with a [ __ ] jingle
so when Jeff Kent is that bat I'm not
falling asleep with the worse beginning
of any song of all time dude they should
have it you know what they should have
they should have this song this is the
song this is the song that should
[ __ ] come up when you now batting
what come on now batting number 25
[Music]
Darryl Strawberry okay you know that
song
hey write more lyrics I'm a sick [ __ ] I
like it sick [ __ ] quick [ __ ] dude
Kanye couldn't look more like he [ __ ]
himself that whole video by the way he's
was like this there's probably a toilet
in that [ __ ] thing it's so big yeah
dude
baseball try by the way baseball is my
favorite sport I'm making a joke but
baseball's favorite sport you know why
cuz there's breaks that's why stop I do
feel like try also but also dude relax
you're in your 30s relax
you know like basketball and [ __ ] like
that's why I didn't like sport it's like
you want the ball that bad [ __ ] take
it dude I got [ __ ] to do I got a look at
emails here here you want the ball so
bad here you know
I'm we're not what we in the NBA I guess
if you're in the NBA it's a different
story getting paid millions of dollars I
mean you know hopefully well this
[ __ ] new setup is awesome the chair
the new chairs this [ __ ] it makes my
back feel good dude chairs were
expensive is [ __ ] dead man good Dan got
two of them
dude what's up with these [ __ ]
rappers Takashi 6:9 I put her on
worldstar there was a picture of him on
world store not with him in Nicki Minaj
the two of them were talking and I and
he was on the right and I wrote the
chick on the right is hot and people
[ __ ] guts people people were
literally like that's that's a dude my
man oh yeah dude hey get it get sarcasm
people are dumb as [ __ ] huh on the
Internet oh dude the [ __ ] the Eminem
[ __ ] when I did the [ __ ] of the video
that went viral when I did the babkin
when I did that video dude people when
people were like yo dude not cool
he's the greatest of all time and you're
just some [ __ ] [ __ ] guy who's
trying to get a name off of him
like I'm imagine if that was what my
thought was to be in the car and be like
dude I gotta make a name for myself I
know what I'll do I'll make fun of the
way I'm in EM raps then it will go viral
and then I'll have a name for myself
I didn't [ __ ] first of all I didn't
know is gonna go viral just because I
said [ __ ] black khun's second of all
mm comedian that's what I do and people
are [ __ ] morons
worldstar posts 400,000 times a day by
the way yeah it's which way far back
dude but anyway this cool worldstar post
some video yeah and yeah it's crazy how
that how that went viral though it would
be insane if Eminem [ __ ] it will be
into people like what if him in him
dishes you and I was like that's
hilarious but then I thought what if he
[ __ ] did though what if he was like
Chris D'Elia
you doing nothing banana man opinion you
know that would be awesome I would be
that's it dude I would be like you know
what I would be like for real if that
happened
one freaky - you're such a [ __ ] I'm a
sick [ __ ] I like a quick [ __ ] I'm a sick
[ __ ] I like a quick [ __ ] I'm a sick [ __ ]
I like the quick [ __ ] anyway I don't
know but that's what's up that's what uh
so that's that's it I don't know yeah
speaking of [ __ ] sports I was at
dinner the other night because sometimes
your boy gets dressed up and goes out
hey dude
it's not often sometimes your boy gets
dressed up and likes to sit down and eat
some Chinese food so I was out and this
guy comes up to me and he's like hey I
hope you don't mind but my my friend is
a big fan okay and then says my friends
have my friends a big fan and he just is
here in LA he's here in LA and he loves
the Lakers can he get a picture and I
thought okay the [ __ ] do I care if he
likes the Lakers or not
right and I was like it tell him to come
on over and he comes over and I was like
you know sit down like we'll just get a
pic whatever and he's like oh okay cool
and the guy goes to take a picture and
he was like should I sit down or so you
stand up I was like not just sit down
the other guy was like well you don't
want him to stand up because they don't
make it look short and I was like that's
not that short and as they were taking
picture I realized I actually think this
guy thinks I'm Pau Gasol I've had it
happen before where somebody is like hey
or something comes up this is this this
guy came up to me he's like hey are you
Pau Gasol and I was like no dude do you
want me to stand up you'll know I'm not
Pau Gasol that way he was like oh okay
it was at the Comedy Store - I think
sometimes people just see people that
they've recognized before and they think
that there's someone else that they
recognize either
that's what happens but dude and I'm
taking this picture and I wish I had the
picture to see the smile on my face the
smile on my face
I actually think here's a smile on my
face looks is is me realizing disc
[ __ ] thinks I'm Pau Gasol
even though I look nothing like him I
did I said this last episode that's my
that's become the most tiresome thing is
that oh you look like this guy oh you
look like that guy when it's just a
long-haired guy with a [ __ ] beard
it's so annoying anyway anyway anyway
Equipe have you guys tried this you
gotta when you walk down the toothbrush
aisle at the store it doesn't take long
to realize that there are lots of
options and many of them are gimmicks
the truth is you really just need
something that guides the simple habits
most of us get wrong when brushing our
teeth and quip knows that quip is an
electric toothbrush that's a fraction of
the cost of the bulkier brushes while
still packing just the right amount of
vibrations to help clean your teeth and
I thought about this because they have a
built-in timer that helps you clean for
the dentist recommended two minutes with
guiding pulses that remind you when to
switch sides and I adhered to it this
morning and I was like oh it's really
nice I don't have to you know figure out
what to do and I know I'm keeping my
teeth clean the subscription plans that
clip has are for your health not just
convenience they deliver the new brush
heads on a dentist recommended schedule
every three months for just five dollars
including free shipping worldwide quip
starts at just 25 dollars and if you go
to get quip calm / Congrats right now
you'll get your first refill pack free
with equip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get quip Calm / Congrats spelled GE tqu
IP comm / Congrats you got to do it my
babies honey now chances are you've
heard of honey the free browser add-on
that finds and applies the best promo
codes every time you shop it may sound
too good to be true honestly it did for
me when I first did it but let's go over
the facts of my babies first you're
probably wondering how much money can
honey really save me turns out honey
has already saved people over eight
and rid million dollars okay so you also
may be thinking honey doesn't work on
the sites that I shop out that shop at
the truth is honey works on over 30,000
sites even Amazon all right how is it
free what's the catch well there's no
catch honey gets a small commission from
sites where honey saves you money so
it's always free in fact 10 million
people trust honey to save them money
every day I use it and it's cool because
every time I check out at Amazon I save
a few dollars and that that adds up dude
so that's why I like it
there's no reason literally to not use
honey it's always free and it takes just
two clicks to install so add honey to
your browser for free right now and join
honey calm / Congrats that's join honey
calm / Congrats so that's what's up you
know I was thinking about this thing
last week thing about this thing last
week or this week actually I mean you
know I'm a sick [ __ ] I like my dick
sucked that's not sick man we all like
it if you got dick you like to get it
sucked anyway I didn't mean to hit that
at that point but it made sense I don't
think about this thing this past week
I'm a sick [ __ ] I like a quick [ __ ] by
the way dude my legs are getting
stronger dude I do squats that's it I do
squats and that's what's happening I saw
I get in the teardrop dude I saw four
can I pick a picture of myself in this
studio and and I took it and I had the
[ __ ] teardrop [ __ ] going on above my
knee and I was like what the [ __ ] oh my
Lee Haney anyway I thought about this
this past week
remember when number one myspace was the
thing
all right so this is a [ __ ] funny
story and I haven't told it in like
years well so many years so it's gonna
be clunky but you guys gonna get the
gist so remember that top okay those you
don't know a lot but guys but don't know
what myspace is I mean you know what it
is but it was like Facebook only it was
MySpace and it was basically the
gangster janky version of Facebook that
now is only filled with like upcoming
artists for some reason and also porn
stars so there was a thing called top
eight and you could have like your top
eight friends shown on your home page
and I it was so annoying to me that
people were like I'll put me in your top
eight which of course annoyed the [ __ ]
out of me because I don't give a [ __ ] if
I'm in your top eight so put me in the
top eight you want put me in you top a
so I made fake profiles for my top eight
this is so something I would do when I
was 26 so I made the top rope
I made eight fake profiles to put them
in my top eight and I made them all Kurt
Russell okay I made them all Kurt
Russell and every profile was a
different had a different icon of
Russell so my top eight were all
different pictures of hurt Russell okay
now here's how you know the Kurt Russell
profiles were fake number one Kurt
Russell wasn't on MySpace and you know
that because you have a brain okay
number two if you clicked on any one of
those profiles you would see each one of
those profiles only had one friend and
they were me who made them hey me okay
now I had to make up fake emails and
fake logins for every one of these Kurt
Russell profiles on MySpace
I forgot some of them but some of them I
would remember so occasionally when I
was bored and feeling like in a silly
mood I would check the
Kurt Russell profile in boxes and [ __ ]
like that and every now and then people
would write them usually it was spam and
I'm talking about maybe it happened a
few times a handful of times but one
time this guy wrote to quote-unquote
Kurt Russell from Italy okay
he writes oh my god I'm the biggest I'm
your biggest fan now he's not talking
about Chris D'Elia I know because I was
nobody I was just a struggling comedian
he said I've seen all of your movies I
love your work you're my favorite actor
Kurt Russell I'm in Italy if there's
anything I can do to try and to audition
or be in your movie I would love to do
it I always wanted to be an actor please
you know you know if there's anything if
you read this so I got this message and
I was like oh my god first of all this
and I don't use this term lightly
brain-dead Italian [ __ ] thinks that
this is the real Kurt Russell now that's
where you're gonna have to get a hey all
right so he so I'm like wow so I I log
out I'm like that's amazing I tell him
my friends like this is [ __ ] amazing
and I'm laughs and we're all laughing
but then it starts to dawn on me all of
the things all of the all of the things
that actors and struggling artists that
move to Hollywood have to sacrifice and
give up they ruin relationships they
lose money they they're they're broke
they're starving right they leave their
[ __ ] big fish in a small small town
and they [ __ ] come out to Hollywood
to try and make it and they're eating
ramen and toast every meal and they give
up everything just to hope to maybe get
an audition for some [ __ ] Kohl's
commercial you know I'm talking about
calls
so I start getting annoyed at the
internet and I start getting annoyed at
at at people and this you know culture
that we have where they just want
everything handed to them this is the
beginning of it this is before the
[ __ ] Kardashians had a career this is
before people were just paying for fit T
you know what I'm talking about now this
guy I'm getting mad at this guy cuz if
this guy oh I'm a huge fan always want
to be an actor if there's anything I can
do if there's anything you could do move
to [ __ ] la drop everything and try
you're not trying you're the baseball of
sports right
you're not trying you're taking breaks
you got the seventh-inning stretch you
[ __ ] so move to LA digit so I
think you know what this is actually
[ __ ] that this guy's doing this so I
write back as quote-unquote Kurt Russell
and I write wow man
I'm humbled thanks a lot it's awesome
that you're a huge fan I actually never
write back but you seem like it got a
good look and you know if you really
want to audition for my next movie about
race cars I say what you can do is you
can put a monologue on tape and why
don't you do the scene from a few good
men where Jack Nicholson says you can't
handle the truth and and put it on tape
and do your best and send it over to me
in a link and I'll watch it and if it's
good I'll cast you in my next movie
about race cars alright now here's the
thing where I judge I'm not a bad guy
for doing this because this guy oh I
already explained how everyone gives up
everything on [ __ ] you know to try
and move out here to be a just get a
glimpse of what the [ __ ] they want for
the dream right now I think if this guy
actually thinks I'm serious and is
actually Kurt Russell
hey man you want to audition for my
racecar movie put on a [ __ ] monologue
from a few good men and he does it then
guess what
his fault okay so I send it and I wait a
few days I check it and when I check it
there's the [ __ ] audition that this
brain-dead Italian [ __ ] is sends me
audition of him doing the scene from a
few good men okay in his Italian accent
now this is the thing first of all I'm
watching it crying laughing rolling
around on my on my apartment floor
rolling around crying laughing watching
this guy doing a few good men in his
Italian accent okay now in my memory now
this was 12 years ago but in my memory
the the dude had and I'm I'm 95% sure
was wearing sunglasses okay and I first
said that was putting sunglasses then I
realize it's because the [ __ ]
audacity he's off screen he's reading
the monologue okay so the disrespect
that this [ __ ] guy has to just try
and get a job in Hollywood by hitting up
Kurt Russell on my space and then
adhering to doing the monologue or
saying he'll do the monologue and then
[ __ ] reading it off-screen trying to
[ __ ] throw me for a loop by just
wearing sunglasses
is so I can't see where his eyes are now
I'm actually but by the beside the fact
that I'm crying tears streaming down my
face like it's the [ __ ] end of
Philadelphia rollin around my carpet I'm
also angry that this [ __ ] doing
this because of how everybody tries to
[ __ ] give everything up in the
Hollywood okay and try to [ __ ] you
know make it so because also I work hard
I go I'm gonna doing open mics every
[ __ ] night and this guy just hit
something worse on myself so I'm like
all right dude pretty I write back as
Kurt Russell pretty good but I need to
see something else too in my racecar
movie I told you it's a race car movie
so I want you to have a big fat
moustache like a racecar driver would
have I want you to have I want you to
wear a big hat like a cowboy hat and I
need to see you after the next monologue
I can't remember what monologue it was
that I showed him to do the next one but
I need to see you get shot and die
because that's the see that's there's a
scene where you have to get shot and die
in the racecar movie
so the next thing okay and then he sends
me another audition tape of him reading
whatever the [ __ ] it is with [ __ ] of
fake big moustache and a [ __ ] like a
Formula one hat wasn't a big hat but it
was kind of like a I think it was a race
car vibe kind of hat and then does the
monologue and then it cuts to him next
to his doorway and he just goes it
pretends he got shot and then falls down
and dies dude it was the at that point
it was the best thing I had ever done oh
man and here's the other thing too I I
don't know where the video must live
somewhere unless I think his name was
Mike something in Italy but the video
was on YouTube I think it's gone now I
wish I [ __ ] saved it I don't know
what link it is but dude if anybody
could it find the Kurt Russell audition
that this guy did force whatever race
car movie I don't think he put in race
car in the title but maybe Kurt
Russell's in the title but I think and
his name is Michael I think he went by
Michael something dude
it's the and it's a few good men it's
the best dude it's so funny man
anyway that's like that that myspace
think that might sway story that was the
best we dude me and my friends would cry
laughing at this [ __ ]
you remember right ah dude it was so
funny anyway you guys got to look for it
I bet somebody could take it up if it's
still out there one of you babies can
dig it up I know the babies could come
out and [ __ ] full force and find the
[ __ ] if it's still out there if it's I
know right now these babies with the
[ __ ] cult that we got going strong if
you can't find it it's not out there
anymore that's how I know how [ __ ]
strong these babies are look we're here
in this [ __ ] log cabin my baby
we built this [ __ ] for you
we built this [ __ ] log cabin for you
dude you hear me not gonna you can hear
that too even if you're not watching the
[ __ ] podcast you're you're listening
to it that's the [ __ ] blog cabin we
had 40 men and some women because we're
not sexist come in and do this uh Mott
and bow quality jeans my babies dude
they sent me some of these jeans quality
jeans my babies they look great they fit
great and they feel great they're very
cool they used to cost you hundreds of
dollars those kinds of jeans right Mott
and bow has permanently changed the game
with $200 designer jeans for half the
price including introducing MA and
Baucom where you can get the most
comfortable premium jeans you will ever
wear for half of what you'd pay
elsewhere for a G or seven jeans these
are luxury jeans for a hundred bucks and
you can only get them at Ma and Baucom
most comfortable because they use the
best in comfort technology
dude this comfort technology honestly
it's gets it's it's you gotta wear these
kinds of things these clothing brands
who use this and you want to be
comfortable but also still look stylish
forget it you got to do this
it's dynamic stretch premium because
they only source their denim from two of
the most well respected denim mills in
the world
these are $200 designer jeans for half
the price plus their September plus
their September savings event means you
will save 20% on everything at Mott and
Baucom slash congratu congratulations
for 20% off everything this is their
best deal anywhere but it is only for
the month of September save 20% during
Mott and boughs September savings event
at Mott and Baucom / Congrats
you guys heard me say it once you heard
me say it hundreds of times the cash hat
you know the cash shot because your baby
it's the simplest way to instantly send
money to friends it's also the number
one app in finance the cash card is a
free customizable debit card that you
can use at stores or ATMs it's linked to
your cash app balance as if it were a
checking account it even lets you direct
deposit your paycheck if you're looking
for an alternative to traditional
banking you're not alone millions of
Americans have already started using the
cash card there's never been a rewards
program like boosts get instant
discounts every single time you swipe
your cash card at coffee shops Chipotle
Shake Shack and beyond just tap a boost
in the app and pay with your cash card
cash app is also the most convenient and
inexpensive way to buy sell and withdraw
Bitcoin twenty years ago something like
cash app would have been hard to imagine
and now it's hard to imagine anything
else and of course when you download the
cash app and enter rewards code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund download the cash app for free on
the App Store or Google Play market I
use it and I use it to send money to
everybody and so if you don't have the
cash app you not get money from me
before we get back into some silliness I
want to talk to you guys about the next
Elder we've got a new Elder and this is
a different style of Elder that we do
but
I'm actually I'm actually proud of this
guy crystally and me I'm proud of this
guy your cult leader is proud of one of
you and I'm going to make you an elder
uh you're gonna pull them up so I can
see elder Shane tur tainment
that's this is an ultimate change at my
man but you know what
Shea Entertainment this guy wrote no
diets work I've tried everything need to
try something else I remember listening
to episode 38 of the congratulations
podcast and Krista Leah had some wise
words he simplified everything for me if
I wanted to this is a little I don't
suggest this this if I wanted to look
like him which is not good I look like a
[ __ ] bird I had to stop with diets
and adopt his lifestyle he doesn't drink
that's true doesn't do drugs true he
doesn't drink soda true he doesn't eat
fast food true he eats good and he works
out every day true for the most part
simple enough simple enough Krista Thea
voice now I did slip up everyone so what
and did I step up every once in a while
yes so do I so do i man was this what
yeah was this more difficult than it
sounds yeah it is difficult did I get
frustrated times and want to quit of
course yes did I stop being a wuss and
commit to this eventually yes did I stop
punishing myself for slipping up yes
that's good that's important too so
there's not beef this may not be for
used to free conch do what you want but
if you want to get into the lock em and
you gotta adopt a hedonistic lifestyle
fellow babies I'm trying to reserve my
seat early shut off to Matt Aleeah for
making me lose an extra two pounds
yesterday find out finding out you ask
Bryan Callen to open for you made me
sweat buckets laughing smart very cool
so this guy goes from what is it what
does he start at 250 he kind of
documents his journey here he gets down
to 222 pounds more 250 goes to he loves
guy lost over this guy lost like 30
pounds I'm just
that's [ __ ] awesome man I think that's
great you know I mean he looks like a
young guy but you know you start younger
so you don't have to [ __ ] do it when
you're older it's harder first of all
and also if you're too big you gonna die
but shut this guy shame for Taemin
that's just [ __ ] awesome man that put
a smile on my face man
it made me it made me happy that this
guy did it and I don't even think like
you know I was like oh yeah you know I'm
sure he's [ __ ] slightly joking about
how you know I inspired him but it's
just cool that he [ __ ] did it
and I'm we're making him an elder dude
he's the new elder so shout him out
congratulations all the babies go tell
him congratulations and hit us up we're
gonna we're gonna DM you on you on
Instagram and we're gonna send you your
pin and certificate that's really great
that you were able to lose that much
weight that's really [ __ ] hard to do
and good on you man do we have some
questions and stuff or what do you want
to do here my buddies my buddies this is
how much I know this is how much I know
this is how happy I am this is how me I
am and how much my people my friends
know how me I am i I am so me and like
the things that I like and don't like
the things I don't like that that I
found out once year after a year of it
going on that my closest friends had a
game night
did I talk about this on the pockets I
think I did actually I'm bringing it up
again and they never invited me they
were talking about game night and I was
like what the [ __ ] and I was like you
guys have game night and they were like
yeah and I was like why have you never
invited me and they're like because we
know you wouldn't want to go that to me
that's some dope [ __ ] man
didn't invite me to game night for a
year because you know me thank you
Thank You friends
okay this is for Jude from June tile at
one take Nate how dumb do people look
when they talk into their phone to text
I guess you do kind of look dumb but
also what else you gonna do I feel like
that that's a good thing to do very
quickly and [ __ ] like that I don't know
if that's even a [ __ ] good question I
mean I guess they kind of look dumb you
can look the problem is you can look
very subdue it like like like you can be
like this if you're in the video pocket
you're talking people to bitch-ass
[ __ ] talk it like this they're
just like this like yeah okay I'll be
there and order the pizza you know what
I mean and you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but that's really the only thing but
you're gonna do it I do it like I do it
like a man you know I mean like just
boob remember this [ __ ] the two-way [ __ ]
that people used to have all the time
and they do be like hey what's up I'm
comin just call each other get
walkie-talkies I always saw [ __ ]
black people doing that dude they love
that [ __ ] they do yo I'd see a black
dude with like a denim jacket and denim
jeans on doing it all the time y'all
what's up I'll be there in a second but
I never saw a white guy do that I wonder
if it's a [ __ ] that's a very odd
thing
it once and I was like I don't get it
nope Garrett at Aldo terrain to rag oh I
mean Cho change it what what are your
thoughts on those Twitter accounts that
beg for money once they have our 200
after haven't I talked about that yeah I
did I talked about it on the [ __ ] I
mean I didn't talk about this
specifically but I talked about it a
little bit on the I think was like an
episode or two ago where it's like the
thing goes viral and it's like all is by
my hair products or if I might listen to
my soundcloud dude it's like dude you
stop trying to [ __ ] get the most you
know stop trying to [ __ ] oh dude I'm
famous now cool let me see if I can make
25 cents on some on some code don't you
how about what people said you those
mass tax works like hey free [ __ ]
type in promo code if you download the
app [ __ ] you know you're gonna add me by
the way you're not gonna text me back
and then also send me a [ __ ] thing
from like whatever [ __ ] here's a
stupid [ __ ] question from Jake beam
at Jake beam pancakes or waffles hey
that's what you sat around and thought
about both hey
how about both cuz they're filled with
sugar both now both pancakes or waffles
now both I usually don't do this then
I'm drunk I'm high in pancake so waffles
now both both they're both amazing so a
lot of places can't can't do pancakes
right though a lot of diners and just
like they just don't do pancakes right
I think the safer bet in the diner is
waffles but if you're gonna make them
make pancakes cuz let me tell you
something right now you don't know how
to make waffles all right and if you
have one of those [ __ ] waffle makers
you're a [ __ ] youre a fuccboi you
know you're a real [ __ ] boy if you have
a waffle maker now if you have a waffle
maker and you've a kids okay cool fine
it's fun thing to do the kids if you're
just like some single dude with a waffle
maker you're a [ __ ] dude you you you you
you [ __ ] girls and you don't call them
back and you're like you think you're
the [ __ ] but really like you're just too
stocky you know and like you suck and
you have like do you think it's cool to
wear like a ring on your pinky and like
maybe you have like a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
I don't say goatee I say you have a
[ __ ] chin goatees dude you got a
[ __ ] goatee bro you have a goatee if
you have a goatee and a waffle maker
you know there's everybody's out there
you know there's a guy with a goatee and
a waffle maker yo that guy honestly he
deserves to [ __ ] sleep in a twin bed
for the rest of a
life that's the [ __ ] worst
you never deserve a bad bigger than a
twin bed you [ __ ] boy if you have a
goatee and a waffle maker I don't give a
[ __ ] what else you have you give to
charity you can cure cancer
you deserve to sleep in a twin bed for
the rest of your life and I hope you
only live to be [ __ ] 48 because
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] now put that on
[ __ ] Instagram
congratulations pod Clips is such a
[ __ ] hell I love it hey how do you
hey that's just how do we not what's it
with all this movement the me2 movement
and the [ __ ] movement where women are
finally like hey this is a problem the
way we're treated how does hip-hop still
get away with yeah come on
I had this [ __ ] suck my dick you're a
[ __ ] ho hi how does it people don't
give a [ __ ] about hip-hop man when it
comes to that kind of [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] about hip-hop and
athletes dude you could literally raise
dogs and slice their [ __ ] balls and
cut their throats and just straight up
as long as you score touchdowns doesn't
Mac Sports and hip-hop is like dude you
could you could literally put out a
viral video of you smacking a girl if
you come up with some [ __ ] jingle ass
hits and go platinum does man how come
nobody's trying to hold these [ __ ]
rappers accountable through [ __ ] dude
for [ __ ] I swear to god Jay Cole could
rob a bank and they could just be like
yeah but you know the bank should have
been [ __ ] this and if here's Octavio
GaN Gonzalez at acht
underscore gongs cool if you had to
choose one pair of sneakers to wear for
the rest of your life what would you
choose
[Music]
[ __ ] man you asked me a year ago I would
have said Jordans but now when I put
Jordans on I've been wearing like low
tops and adidas so much that now if you
sometimes Jordans they're like too tight
and high you know what I mean I don't
know I don't know one for the rest of
your life like if I got to where I had
to wear them during it with suits - I
don't know man maybe I would just get
those [ __ ] web shoes those [ __ ]
[ __ ] shoes that people wear with the
toe shoes that you see Rogan wear
sometimes
[ __ ] Jill Rogan rocking those [ __ ]
finger toed shoes Sasso wears them you
know sass those got them - love those
guys
but yeah they got those toe shoes saw a
guy wearing those at this [ __ ] gym
class I did the other day I did a gym
class dude your boys finished [ __ ] by
the way I did a gym class I'm not sure
at all I did it and [ __ ] killed it
and I'm not sore at all dude my
shoulders are a little bit sore because
I did a lot of reverse flyes but dude
he's got them teardrops what the [ __ ]
dude what the [ __ ]
hey guys are my hip bones crying cuz
I've got those [ __ ] quad teardrops
hey careful knees you don't want to get
wet are my hips crying cuz I can do
squats for days dude my legs are so
skinny but I'm getting those [ __ ]
teardrops above my knees hey dude
there's [ __ ] Johnny hips cry that's
what they're gonna call me from now on
Johnny hips cry I'm [ __ ] talk about
change it that's gonna be my [ __ ]
name on Twitter and Instagram
Johnny hips cry Joh hny hips cry dude
dude
know why they call me Johnny hips cry
wow that's that's the dumbest thing I've
ever [ __ ] said Johnny hips cry Johnny
hips cry leave this part out of the song
though just say this to your friends and
then rap Donnie hips cry Johnny hips cry
Johnny hippies cry like dude I'm 38 I
should have a family don't want to have
a family yet wasn't sure now I'm
changing my mind I kind of maybe would
want a family someday but I didn't want
a family for 30 but that's because I
always thought people complaining about
the family then they'd come back around
and they say they'd come back around and
they'd say but it's the best thing ever
but I'm so tired all the time and my son
shits everywhere it's everywhere
gotta clean his ass they hate it so much
always crying but it doesn't matter
because he's the light of my life how
the [ __ ] does that make any sense
I'm a good freestyle dude I'm a good
freestyler because I hate rappers rhyme
dude you rhyme bro talk about real
issues dude
you soon want yeah it was married like
12 years ago did want kids but didn't
really think about it but now I feel
like I do after that I didn't want kids
I didn't want kids for about ten years
cuz I would always see my friends with
kids so tired she said she didn't wanna
be at time plus I love that hedonistic
lifestyle always did what I want when I
walk got cuffing when I walk got
everything went to ride a different
wanted to see you have to text anyone
I'm still kind of maybe walk here cuz
I'm 38 I don't wanna die don't wanna die
don't wanna do that if if a rapper went
on The Breakfast Club and did a
freestyle like that guess what you got a
fan for life dude anyway dude I'm
[ __ ] getting out of here
it's been over an hour what the [ __ ] do
you want from me dude I can't wait to
get this [ __ ] lock cabin going and
get you [ __ ] who choose to come
cuz free cons and we're just chilling
getting [ __ ] and sucked doing the
hedonistic lifestyle and putting it to
the test
in the meantime come out and see me on
the follow-the-leader tour we [ __ ]
love you and by we I mean me and me me
and Johnny hips cry Chris Thalia a ka
Johnny hips cry [ __ ] loves you
[ __ ] follow the leader' tour
Chris D'Elia calm there's [ __ ] what do
you want for me there's merch where it
support the [ __ ] PCAST I'm coming a
[ __ ] I'm coming to Canada I'm playing
Carnegie Hall I'm going to a place
called Snoqualmie Washington for some
reason probably bags why am I going to
Snoqualmie probably because of bags
Miami Fresno Bakersfield Austin San
Antonio YouTube channel I'm telling you
you're gonna want to check out this
episode on YouTube because we've got a
whole new digs here we've got a whole
new digs that'll go up either tomorrow
or probably tomorrow a man on fire watch
that incorrigible white male black
common comic like white male black comic
watch that and that's what's up dude my
babies you guys Rock thank you for
listening this is [ __ ] Johnny hips cry
signing off
[Music]